Fridays
they've got a Friday
[Music]
you
so beautiful mother [ __ ] better be
alive Jack the sun's out the birds a
chirp but most importantly you've got
the reefer of life
Uncle Joe over here wishing you a happy
Friday wishing you I don't even know
what the [ __ ] I'm wishing I'm just here
to tell you it's a beautiful [ __ ] day
grab your balls sniff those
[ __ ] cuz you're gonna need a
[ __ ] we're going deep in the murky
waters of the underworld this weekend
you're anyway it's Friday that's it all
week long and good work you put up with
[ __ ] you [ __ ] to get my [ __ ] you don't
give a [ __ ] about a we up got the world
by the balls you understand reefer
update what I usually do is the last
after all my reef is together and I get
one big [ __ ] explosion I've got ready
on here I've got [ __ ] wedding cake
I've got JJ I've got everything we're
going for [ __ ] broke understand but
Joey enough with the chitter chatter
spark that Soulja [ __ ] I'm
trying I'm trying I'm still gonna [ __ ]
up from nobody and some stars last night
the night before you know I'm a star
and sit
I only go clap my hafter I'd talk to you
can't suck this I've got a nice joint of
debt in the [ __ ] car we go get that
to fill her up you know I'm saying but
for now we don't need I just want to let
you know that's it I don't even know
what the [ __ ] alone let you know I won't
let you know it's time to [ __ ] get
high it's time to smoke a bone and
reflect on your week and what you want
for the weeks to come
you understand me because you don't want
this only that's better
the more you put in the more you get
like the man said and when you lose
control you'll weep the harvest you have
some understanding that's the type of
[ __ ] we're dropping tonight
nice this is this is what it's all about
friends a little Bowl and you're off on
your merry way with a new [ __ ] added
to it you understand me
why not blow hey everybody's got a
fucked-up had a too when they wake up I
don't know they're not gonna like me
what am I gonna do give us a [ __ ]
there's a [ __ ] what they think it's when
you take [ __ ] [ __ ] okay if I
gave a [ __ ] they take it but I still be
here I don't think so so that's sitting
like that
I'm have to [ __ ] that you don't meet
them I hid these things so [ __ ] hard
to it's the pipe is [ __ ] dead this
pipe is [ __ ] dead but at least you
got the change I change this morning and
now over your weekend to let you know
it's gonna be alright
I don't give a [ __ ] what they die it's
gonna be okay but it always is 53 years
now they were telling me I was in
trouble and you know what I'm still
[ __ ] here swinging dick time to go
[ __ ] themselves they can't [ __ ]
control or [ __ ] you are [ __ ] moved to
Cuba legit communist [ __ ] you think
you're dealing with some Donald Trump
[ __ ] [ __ ] I'm the real deal
[ __ ] I've lived it
and that's it and that's it now we'll
check them with you guys after I make
the pickup and water pick up to one I
[ __ ] Jew I got a couple connections
to bump into today but when I come back
I'll show you the [ __ ] loot don't
forget about me have a good day remember
love yourself because sometimes it's all
you got
stay boy